boy what a weekend for the rebels now
their home opener isn't against just any
team it's against
the team the team that some referred to
as the team up north unlv in reno the
rivalry dates back 45 years
who's not ready for the battle the
battle for the fremont cannon
yeah you've got your backs against the
wall we are up against it
now they're going to find out about us
we have a long hard night of work
this is the biggest game of the year for
us in nevada there's nothing that
compares to this game you can go all the
way back to the 60s there were the
hippies rebels and radical reno
we know how big of a game this is not
one person is just locked in on this
you know we want to protect the cannon
and keep it here in las vegas
this game means a lot when this one and
all other misforgivings are forgotten
fremont's howitzer is on the line right
now it's painted
home red only if it's stolen will it be
spray painted blue
fremont cannon is priceless like the
game i mean the goal is always the same
you know that's to get a win i said the
only thing that's really different is
that you know we of course want to keep
the cannon red
so that's really the only thing you know
the goals of saying we just want to win
the ever brewing battle has gone on now
for 45 years
31 straight but this will be the first
time the game will be played on the very
date of the anniversary of the silver
state
october 31st 1864. it's also the first
game ever played by unlv
inside allegiant stadium there's a 2
billion dollar stadium and we want to
protect the name on the front and
we want to protect the name on the back
too and you know go out there and show
a show off for our family that can
attend to the game and stuff like that
is a chance to have fans so
i feel like it's going to be a really
good game and it's going to be a great
atmosphere
it's a big deal scores have been carved
in stone as reminders in the corner
he's got it still has a free run all
right samantha